you
hi everyone I'm zareen I'm Jeff and
today we're going to play a game called
phantasmal city of darkness yay what's
phantasmal well it's an indie survival
horror procedurally generated video game
good um it's it's cool like your first
to itself as phantasmal city of darkness
and it's also going by the name
phantasmal on steam or it's on early
access and it was a kick started game
but now it's on Steam early access as
well if you want to check check it out
and it's from a developer called I'm OB
ok so tell so they're ado let's get into
it get into it so this game came from a
Kickstarter right yep that's right yeah
um I think some time ago maybe like a
year ago although it only came onto
steam early access in April this right
ok it's pretty recent yeah so the whole
stick is you are an investigator
straight stuck in the city of Kowloon in
Hong Kong yeah and your objective is to
get out to the exit like you need to get
out of here just ok well i mean i can i
can get behind that objective that makes
sense the problem is between you and the
exit there's like a bunch of nightmarish
strange creatures that is a less less
favorable yeah and ok a little them are
very like I see some of the lovecraftian
yeah inspiration as well as would be
silent hill yeah yeah and as you can see
you can pick up like planks and stuff
around great wow that was really easy to
get off the wall I know useful no this
prying for us and the whole thing about
this game is each time you play it it's
different than that is procedurally
generated roguelike kind of things ok
and you gotta find your way to the exit
so in the top right corner there is a
well I want to say a compass yeah
offensive a service and it's constantly
pointing at we're also to go ok spider
sir this is that's the first of the
creatures we
mm-hmm the other that you saw earlier
when we were testing the game like I
kind of freaky zombie locating Oh God
okay the point is like you're not
supposed to make noise the gaming cards
you to try and avoid I do that you come
across okay rather than fighter which is
why how easy is that it's actually quite
easy make a point of being stealthy and
just has to be pretty careful crouch all
the time yeah and not use your
flashlight as much like I'm doing over
here because do they notice your
flashlight all right yes so the
flashlight draws the attention of the
creatures very quickly okay as well as
making any sort of noise yeah in
addition to that there's like this on
this meter which you don't see but on
every level if you make too much noise
when it reaches a certain point the
levels big monster will come after you
and that thing can't be killed so what
do you do do you have some time to run
and try and find the end of the level is
that you're in the ocean pretty much oh
great so you know don't make too much
noise do yes um try not to shoot
shooting in general is bad ah spiders oh
good good and see its head but it's
actually not quite the spider what's its
head what's his head no I wanted what's
in bed okay do or you all know
everything I'm just in the compass I
like this your city and every it's kind
of there's quite a few token around you
like a lot of dudes yeah Andrey well lit
in this particular area to some places
are definitely yeah well talk of
another's oh this guy's to be right
around like please don't look at me it's
okay McCain into that wall right now
literally I'm gonna see the King to the
wall that'll work well for everybody
involved the other thing is some areas
have light switches so if you find the
light switch and switch it on an
illuminated room and that'll stop
monsters from respawning oh wow quickly
level if you want to come back to it
although I can't understand why someone
would want to go back I guess it just
makes things easier if you're lost if
you're lost like me coming to dead ends
like this that's
no although I don't know what these like
they're glowing what these are yeah like
rocks I mean like you know all right oh
ok I don't stacked I don't yes no
question sir how are you deciding where
to go I'm waiting at that compass right
all right hmm and you can see I've got a
key choice well and 0730 through here I
don't think this door is open a boil
every time I've pulled planks off the
door it has been fun Oh which is quietly
so I guess you couldn't get in the nails
off off jarrell and well that's okay
we're doing any work we're getting
places what's that oh is that it is that
the exit I think it is oh my gosh i love
it when we succeed at me sorry phone
really cool no I great it is ever oh
alright what are those awful sounds I
don't know your buddy you have to tell
us cuz we can actually hear very much
see this is just pitch black darkness I
can't yeah well we the flashlight
since I've also got flares in my
inventory which I can choose to throw
out okay like the monsters are drawn to
them yeah okay that seems like it would
cause more harm than good what is all I
throw it away from myself the tips do
say like don't put the nice to be up
with the place yeah well players are a
pretty big staple in our games yes Oh as
this procedural generation for that
little oh god that was loud everything
loud did that feel outta falaschi for
noak smashed something on accident oh no
now we're just walking to her on us no
I'm so clumsy because Lulu's gonna come
get us no have to make it so that when
we finish we draw him there yeah well to
show you guys what it looks like because
it's very uh he's something yeah
something okay oh ho hunting rifle yes
please that seems like the opposite of
quiet yeah so the last time I was
walking around and I shot a couple of
BC's that was enough to like draw the
cthulhu guy so the noise from shooting
delaying you cuz it's like giving you
stuff but at the same time if you use
them it's yeah it's really odd because
it's like you know screw yourself you
have to sneak around these guys but if
you come across sling if you have to
confirm one just shoot it but if you
shoot too much it was all a big one that
you can't kill so you know don't do to
that there's so many guys thank God they
can't see you at all room I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm I did like you oh no nice oh
god I can't even see what's
it is so hard right oh no my goodness
okay that's okay no it's a cool tool is
Connie Castle haha right let's just
broke we should run right we should just
find the exit it's okay we oh okay so
it's faded away i think oh no no oh just
hit me come in one shot so it doesn't
count as one shot if you're already like
buying more again okay here we go and
the maps go to be different this time
okay but yeah basically don't shoot so I
don't understand the hunting rifle
because I don't know maybe it's like a
shirt once and then wait a bit angry you
know I guess like shoot if absolutely
necessary otherwise started yeah pretty
much actually the first time i played
this game I tried it when it was in its
very very early alpha stages yeah it was
on the rift oculus rift yeah which was
quite it was so much more difficult to
shoot on that thing yeah there it was I
wouldn't want to place on rifter I think
I was scared the motions of the filter
is quite interesting yeah it's
definitely something I'm unaccustomed to
in a first person shooter though yeah
that being said the game still is in its
early access sir plenty will change
between down release I'm [ __ ] hey fun
fact that symbol in the middle of our
arrow that's pointing us to the exit
yeah it actually means exit in kind it's
the kanji thing really Stephanie's
that's amazing which is why I was like
oh so it must be pointing to the exit oh
my gosh little fat few arguments such a
disadvantage
all right okay I really want to
encounter the shadow things again they
were really interesting that sounds
terrible Wow all right let's write all
these comments that's good idea these
calories class I guess we should oh what
was that oh that's just a and bird what
even oh no my sanity meat is going away
so if you look at things oh you that
feel good you're gonna look at monsters
too long because you know major you lose
sanity and that's a bad thing do they
chase you if you run away oh yeah don't
know uh they do bang against doors and
stuff okay well no no he knows bathrooms
Oh bathroom is that red thing meeting of
getting it I don't know what that means
it's just cuz it's not it's a lot of us
now it's not pointing oh there are dudes
in here so we should probably get a move
on how do you know say walk through the
door what did that yeah answer because I
sold yeah oh no this is a dead end the
eggs needs be
oh no hang on no way good told a whole
season of the cabinet yeah so like
everything you do makes noise walking
bass toys walking makes less noise oh
crap around him all sneaky-like walking
makes a little bit of noise sprinting
makes the most noise right and crouch
stealth walking which is what i'm doing
now crawling makes zero noise okay so
and we've reached the exit so that's
okay yeah so accessorize and what's not
successfully oh okay good so we made it
back to the second level yeah yeah how
much is this on early access student
1499 and I think this is it's changed a
lot so the devil's up like are
constantly making improvements even on
the main logging screen as days since
last update I i think you know they're
putting a lot of work into constantly
dancing and taking feedback as well oh
well some notes a little backstory okay
so there is a story as well the walled
city has always been haven for the
downtrodden the weary the hopeless
sounds like some place you want to go
walking into moody what the back into
heroines dark familiar embrace I wet/dry
the bad news is when something wrong
somewhere I wasn't expecting this is
like a hospital or IAM right looks like
some sort of clinic yeah cool so I'd say
that's the heroin user was trying to
open a clinic for people health kit I
just met heroin users dude I just want
to know what that red pointy thing is
like it's my waist we gonna text once
and our guy just can't shake it he just
remembers that one time he got hit from
the front I see okay that's a good song
well maybe let's okay will before we
finish let's just make a racket shall we
ok and go down oh all the help a little
throw shooting lasers out of it go back
is that it looks at the medic in
whatever it is is killing me oh but eve
of kuphulu ok not actually cooler we
should probably all right it's like
spiders scrub all right all right I
think it was pretty solid and that is
how you die um so then it just reboots
and you get to have another go at with
with many uh procedurally generated
games yeah there you go and find good
tactics and yes yeah the map changes
every time and you do come across new
monsters later on as well yeah found in
the past so yes that's phantasmal city
of darkness if you want to check it out
some steam early access at the moment
thanks for watching yeah